僕はこれはね巨大スーパーボールを作るとがいやほど行ってきました第がどれも失敗に
終わっている僕はなんぞやってもなんだ言っても何度やっても何度やっても失敗ズレと
プログライド
何度イッなんだってを酸っぱいするそんな僕には新しい希望の光がきました今回は
こちらお家稀です
これは何か分かるか私はそんな詳しいわけじゃない
ただなんとなく調べてたらあってプラスチック年度っていうのかなちょっと見ていき
ましょう
俺じゃあ食べれば形が川でらしいです24入ってるみたいですねこれ着た cocco
スーパーボウよく弾むスーパーで言って感やレジャー
じゃぞこれだこれを張ってだ作り方なんですけども書いてある通り熱いお湯にこれを
いれば形が動かせるようになるらしいです把握
水お湯に入れて半分くらいで柔らかくなるらしいんですけどあ強いが初10度以上だし
待て待て80ドってさぁお風呂じゃダメだよね
もうちょっとお湯止めてくるわ午前の暗い赤もてたお湯止めてくる
お風呂のお湯じゃないかね
配色でおりまで80度以上ということでお風呂にバッドね入れようと思ったんですけど
ねみたいです敦代80度以上なら土の皆さん作る時は温度に気をつけましょう危ない
から京都のお湯を張るをつくってこの言われのセットを10個準備しました ok
240個のおゆまるを使っていけるよいける
っていけないと困るそろそろ今回は言ってるでしょスーパーボウルが作れるよくはず
るって書いてあるんですよそれを240部準備して全部でとに打ち込んで全部動かせる
ようにして練武くっつけて巨大なセイバー俺の駅やがですよ
すごいめっちゃ普通に綺麗なんですけど触った患者するところです
山力は if 眼力がちゃんとありますいけるいける
いる i 低減全部出ましたこれはなかなか一緒
いやー濃い物量的には完全に超巨大するバコール作れるレベルの良あると思いますで
良い子
まずでそろそろ成功させたいんだよ巨大スーパーボウルはなんか物理的に不可能なのか
なとか思ってきたりしてるんでちょっと倍音と跳ねて欲しいと思っております入って
くださっ酒を家の中に入れていきましょう
見ないでこれ大丈夫かなぁなちょっと強くねば
うわこれさぁを言われ死んじゃう暑すぎてちょっと早速今ネットの中に置い悪いれてみ
ましょう
いることによってどのように変わるとかすごいポイントですね
3分ぐらいで柔らかくなるらしいです全部も結構入れちゃっていい結構入れちゃいます
はずじゃなかった
じゃあちょっといじると2部に分けてから加熱も沿いを呼ぶよそうかな
お湯が全然足りねーなー
これねちょっと3分ぐらい待ってみましたん
結構降ってきました心にとかね大迷惑になってねサー基本的にちゃんとお湯に入ってる
奴が結構多くなってきてるんでもうそろそろは形が作れるのかなと思いますあともう
ちょっとちょっと得ると取ってみようかな
はマットやま待ておまえらさぁあとまあ小川じゃないかこのまま形など4バスよってた
まえだこれは混ぜるまずやー
徐々に
水分を取らできないからタオルをしたもう取り取り出せる飛びだ鳥だこれとりあえず
しかないよ
ブービー以下安全ヌードル
チェーンぬーんっ
もう舌みたいな待って本当にあのびっくりするくらい熱いてよろしい釣るぞ前の形を
つける
忙しい忙しい
まあ名前も付けたかまくる均じゃ第二版いきましょう出社いきますって
のハァハァパパバッター淡白だよねー
お箸をとすっのハーブとああいう危ないからスペルああああっああ水分うああ
あーーーーっっっ
トレジャーネットいっぱいがっっ台数バブルの花ちゃんも作っちゃいます茶荘
に時代が来てる気がするぞまずしっかり曲げていくことが大事ですね美味しい
ターンスクロー
あっはぁっなんだかわかんなには2月って謝ったんで中から熱湯が出てきて温泉回を2
今やけど今やけどでは中にまた水分がいたってことか
思
も彼の未確認生物になってしまったんですては水あたり山で跳ねていきましょう
よしまこんなもんでしょ一応スーパーマンが出来ましたがおいておくとどんどん形がね
また崩れていくんですよ
では冷蔵庫行ってきます
はーはっはっはできました多いまでで作った巨大スーパーボールです冷凍庫に入れて
一気に冷やしたんでかなくても形も崩れません
ちょっといびつです書いてるんでもよく弾むスーパーボウルができるよってハマっ
ちゃうでしょ
第じゃあ
まあ
ああ待ってもらって跳ねたでも半値たような感じだよね
パー
あまりカメラ下へ男性的な要求するが弾同僚が実にスーパーこれは税効果も少ないぞ
ですげーなーああーーーーっっっだ
def